sous le cadavre de Marius Lac un morceau
de papier
couvert de sang
[Musique]
7 novembre 1998 en Corrèze dans le petit
village de Darney
[Musique]
ce matin comme il en a l'habitude Henri
serra instituteur à la retraite sort
promener son chien
et tout de suite il sent bien que
quelque chose n'est pas normal
on est arrivé ici à l'air de jeu des
enfants le chien par habitude va faire
un petit tour bon mais je ne m'en suis
pas soucier j'ai pris le chemin et le
chien m'a rejoint
j'ai vu que mon chien ne chassait pas
bien j'ai vu ensuite qu'il m'avait
légèrement bon je ne m'en suis pas
inquiété ensuite
pire il est il tombait alors là j'étais
vraiment
désemparé j'ai fait très vite pour
arriver à la maison le chien est monté
tout seul dans la voiture et on est
parti au vétérinaire
immédiatement Henri c'est rare rejoint
la petite ville d'Égletons où il a son
vétérinaire habituel le docteur brousse
le chien de Monsieur serra semble très
mal en point il présente tous les
symptômes d'un empoisonnement sa bave
est étrangement bleue une injection
d'atropine suffira à sauver le chien de
Monsieur serra mais le docteur brousse
est très surpris car ce jour-là
plusieurs chiens lui ont été apportés
dans le même état et trois d'entre sont
morts
les symptômes se déclenchent très
rapidement dans les cinq dix minutes et
ils peuvent être extrêmement violents et
entraîner la mort de l'animal dans le
quart d'heure ou la demi-heure qui suit
c'est à dire que le temps que
le propriétaire amène son chien chez un
le vétérinaire le plus proche
il peut arriver et le chien en a eu
beaucoup de chiens qui sont morts sur la
table avant que on puisse rien faire
un qui est les propriétaires de chiens
empoisonnés vont fouiller les environs
et ils vont découvrir en plusieurs
points du canton de petites boulettes
bleues comme celle-ci
la gendarmerie est immédiatement saisie
de la faire
[Musique]
ces boulettes ressemblaient à de la
chair à saucisse assez grossière et
avait la forme de de la main d'une
poignée comme si on s'en est étonné le
début la personne avait un saut et
comprimé la chair à saucisse et la jetée
qui peut donc répondre ainsi des
boulettes mortelles
les enquêteurs effectuent des
prélèvements sur les lieux des
empoisonnements les échantillons sont
envoyés pour analyse au laboratoire de
l'École Vétérinaire de Lyon
quelques jours plus tard les résultats
tombent le poison bleu contenu dans les
boulettes est un insecticide en
paillettes dénommé carbo Furon
on l'utilise notamment dans la culture
du maïs à l'époque il est facile de s'en
procurer dans les coopératives agricoles
et dans les grandes surfaces
spécialisées
les boulettes bleues font des ravages en
deux mois 20 chiens sont empoisonnés les
gendarmes prennent la faire au sérieux
toutes les hypothèses sont envisagées
vous pensez à un facteur on peut penser
aussi à des gens qui travaillent dans
les abattoirs parce que oui il faut se
procurer comme une quantité importante
de marchandises
les gens qui peuvent avoir bien entendu
qui peuvent être casser régulièrement
par des animaux oui tel un facteurs
éventuellement on peut faire partie des
pistes à explorer
bon on s'en rend vite compte malgré tout
que c'est pas que c'est pas des pistes
mais bon tout a été vérifié bien entendu
par cette cellule
et ces pistes là ont été écartés les
gendarmes sont dans l'impasse mais
l'enquête va faire un bon spectaculaire
et cela grâce à l'intuition d'un ancien
gendarme à la retraite
22 octobre 1998 la gendarmerie reçoit la
visite d'un certain Marius Lac retraité
de la gendarmerie il a 59 ans et il a
son opinion sur le mystère des chiens
empoisonnés
Marius lakhabite la région il connaît
bien les chasseurs d'ailleurs lui aussi
partage cette passion pour lui pas de
doute l'empoisonneur est un chasseur
pervers
des boulettes en grande quantités ont
été découvertes à ce que l'on appelle
des rendez-vous de chasseurs c'était sur
la commune de Saint-Hilaire Foissac à un
carrefour de chemin
[Applaudissements]
les chasseurs viennent avec leur 4x4
vers leur véhicule les chiens sont
excités le coffre à peine ouvert les
chiens sortent et les boulettes se
trouvent là les chiens ont ingurgité ces
boulettes et sont morts très rapidement
[Musique]
Marius Lac en est convaincu ce sont les
chiens de chasse que l'empoisonneur
aurait pour cible
la nouvelle se répand dans toute la
Corrèze et la population commence à
s'inquiéter
les gens sont venus nous voir on a reçu
des coups de fil pour nous demander ce
que ce qu'on savait quel conseil en
pouvait leur donner on a consulté
pharmacien toxicologues vétérinaire
surtout pour expliquer comment faire
pour éviter la mort de leur animal
les faire voir les faire vomir de
préférence
le 25 mars 1999 une information
judiciaire est ouverte au Tribunal de
tulle la justice est maintenant saisie à
cette époque la criminologue Francette
vigneront s'intéresse de près à la faire
c'est elle qui va dresser cette carte où
elle répertorie en rouge les zones
touchées par les boulettes de carburant
et très vite cette femme va dresser le
profil de celui que l'on appelle
désormais le tueur de chien c'est
quelqu'un qui connaît très bien les
territoires de chasse donc pour les
connaître aussi bien
il est difficile de d'y parvenir sans
pratiquer soi-même la chasse sans
connaître soi-même les territoires de là
à dire que c'est un chasseur lui-même on
en est pas très loin parce que quelqu'un
qui qui s'en prendrait à la chasse sans
prendre manifesterait contre les
chasseurs mais ne s'en prendrait pas à
leur chien
confectionner des boulettes empoisonnées
pour aller les déposer pour qu'elle tue
le plus sûrement possible
révèle une personnalité extrêmement
dangereuse c'est à dire quelqu'un qui a
la maîtrise
de son acte qui est précis
méticuleux qui prend raisonnablement des
risques qui connaît très bien le
territoire donc il y a dû faire des
repérages bon ça veut dire que cette
personne là ne s'arrêtera pas en effet
pendant toute l'année 1999 les
empoisonnements continuent
en 2000 le tueur de chien étant son
rayon d'action 140 chiens sont victimes
des boulettes bleues mais le coupable
lui reste toujours insaisissable
jusqu'au début de l'année 2001 où il va
commettre une erreur
[Musique]
le 9 février 2001 près du village des
Farges la propriétaire d'un chien
empoisonné aperçoit un véhicule suspect
immédiatement elle a l'alerte légendaire
samedi matin donc une dame se présente à
la gendarmerie d'Egletons afin de
déposer une plainte pour en posant le
monde de son chien elle fait part aux
enquêteurs du fait qu'elle a croisé un
véhicule partiellement immatriculé RM 19
ce véhicule de la croisée non loin son
domicile ou son chien était empoisonné
elle fait donc l'association entre ce
véhicule et l'empoisonnement de son
animal le 19 correspond au département
de la Corrèze l'empoisonneur serait donc
comme on le soupçonnait un corrézien
mais le témoin a également identifié le
modèle du véhicule il s'agit d'une
fourgonnette Renault Express de couleur
blanche
or il y a justement quelqu'un dans la
région qui en possède une
plus tard la rencontre des amis avec
lesquels elle en discute
et ces derniers lui déclare ou l'informe
que ce véhicule présente les mêmes
caractéristiques que celle de Monsieur
bandoulier Roland Roland bandoni et
quelqu'un de connu dans la région c'est
un notable un négociant en vain
mais ce qui retient l'attention des
enquêteurs c'est que bondoni est aussi
un chasseur il possède un terrain de
chasse privée dans la région
il cherche d'ailleurs à l'agrandir et
pour cette raison il est en délicatesse
avec de nombreux autres chasseurs
[Musique]
monsieur bondoni était connu pour avoir
le verbe haut et menacé facilement
ses voisins ou les personnes qui
voulaient récupérer des territoires ou
des anciens territoires les personnes
qui lui avaient donné ces droits de
chasse lui avertir donc c'est l'avait
mis un petit peu en colère et
je crois que ces personnes là les
avaient donné
des chasseurs à d'autres chasseurs on
nous a parlé d'animaux morts de je parle
de bétail de vengeance même des feux des
bois qui aurait été mis au Grand Prix
feu par vengeance mais les gens n'ont
jamais d'avoir déposé plainte parce
qu'ils ont peur de représailles chasseur
controversé homme caractériel parfois
violent tous la colle parfaitement avec
le portrait de l’empoisonneur pour les
gendarmes des glotons Roland bandoni
fait désormais figure de suspect numéro
1 reste maintenant à procéder à son
arrestation
12 février 2001 à la gendarmerie
d'Égletons il est 9h du matin
ce jour-là la Renault Express blanche de
Roland bondoni vient spontanément se
garer sur le parking et les enquêteurs
sont surpris l'homme ne vient pas se
rendre il vient déposer une plainte il
affirme que sa chienne est morte la
veille victime à son tour des boulettes
bleues
mais ce que Roland bandonning ignore
c'est que les gendarmes le soupçonnent
d'être lui-même le tueur de chien
j'ai pris bien sûr sa plainte après en
avoir référé au parquet parce qu'on
savait pas d'être manquer la attitude
adoptée à son égard alors que bondoni
est interrogé à l'extérieur sur le
parking un gendarme inspecte la voiture
du suspect et l'enquêteur est attiré par
un étrange détail sur le rétroviseur du
véhicule de Roland bondoni
un de mes personnel aperçu ce qui lui
semblait du poison du carburant bleu
dans le rétroviseur de la voiture de
monsieur mandeli donc il revient à la
brigade me fait signe discrètement de le
suivre dehors et je là je constate moi
aussi que dans le rétro il y a du
produit bleu qui pourrait correspondre à
aux poisons il semble même y avoir des
paillettes de carbo Furon à l'intérieur
de la voiture comme si l'on avait
transporté des quantités importantes du
dangereux insecticide
dans les locaux de la gendarmerie Roland
bondoni est intrigué par les
allers-retours des gendarmes ils sont
bien qu'il se passe quelque chose
[Musique]
alors il va trouver un moyen de quitter
les lieux rapidement il s'est énervé il
s'est emballé et il a fait un malaise
cardiaque il s'est levé il s'est écroulé
et a renverser du mobilier et sorti
comme un fou de la brigade donc j'ai
rendu compte aussitôt au parquet qui m'a
dit donc là dans ces cas-là il faut
l'interpeller le mettre en garde à vue
les gendarmes prennent aussitôt la
voiture de Roland bondoni en chasse
pendant plus de 7 km ils vont le suivre
jusqu'à ce petit chalet qui est le
pavillon de chasse de Roland Denis le
suspect est alors interpellé
dans la fourgonnette la police
scientifique va prélever les particules
bleues à l'aide d'un tampon noir
[Musique]
on en retrouve en 9 points différents de
l'habitacle aussi bien à l'avant
[Musique]
bondoni assiste à la scène un
perturbable
monsieur bandoni est resté froid comme à
certaines situations et comme il est
resté froid par la suite lorsqu'il a été
mis en garde à vue il n'a pas eu de
réaction violente à part le fait qu'il a
refusé de signer les scellés prétextant
que c'était l'évolution de son chien
Roland bondoni prétend en effet que
c'est son chien intoxiqué qui a
régurgité un peu partout du carbo Furon
dans la fourgonnette
l'ennui c'est que le laboratoire qui va
analyser les prélèvements va le
contredire d'après l'expertise le carbo
Furon trouvé à l'avant de L'Express
blanche est un produit sec il n'a jamais
été ingéré par un animal
d'où provient carbofurant de qui qui
était qu'on a retrouvé dans la voiture
de bandoni provient-il de sa chaîne ou
pas si on en croit les analyses
toxicologiques non Stéphane c'était pas
le même carbo furent donc voilà
maintenant à défense elle va dire le
contraire en disant que c'est la chienne
qui a agité qu'il a avalé par mégarde
enfin voilà mais c'était pas plausible
Roland bondonnier mis en examen pour
empoisonnement
il n'est pas incarcéré mais soumis à un
contrôle judiciaire il lui est interdit
de séjourner dans la région et ce
jusqu'au procès
seulement les empoisonnements continuent
et l'inquiétude monte encore d'un cran
car des boulettes sont retrouvées pour
la première fois dans le centre ville
d'Égletons
autour de la place principale
et surtout aux environs de l'école
dans le village de Darney également des
boulettes empoisonnées ne semblent plus
seulement viser les chiens et la
première fois c'était ciblé uniquement
dans le bourg et sur une maison dans le
lotissement après on a retrouvé des
boulettes beaucoup plus à l'entrée du
bourg qui visait visiblement plus un
chasseur particulièrement il n'y avait
pas que des chiens qui pouvaient être
touchés là cette fois-ci on était
vraiment avec des enfants qui pouvaient
pourquoi pas porter à la bouche cette
ces boulettes c'est c'était d'une belle
couleur bleue ça pouvait ressembler à
des bonbons à un enfant en bas âge
pouvait très bien avoir la tentation de
porter ça à sa bouche
toute la région s'interroge comment se
fait-il que les empoisonnements
continuent alors que bondoni n'a plus le
droit de mettre les pieds en Corrèze
est-il innocent serait-il possible qu'on
se soit trompé de coupable tous les
chasseurs des alentours se mobilisent à
l'image de Suzanne Ségurel
la réaction c'est venue que on a dit il
faut qu'on fasse des gardes de nuit
pour essayer de le voir parce que il y
avait les gendarmes il y avait mais il
fallait bien qu'on donne un coup de main
donc on s'est mis à fédé à faire des
gardes de nuit régulièrement les
week-ends
étaient assez excédés et puis bon
certains allaient même à nous dire si on
les trouve avant vous certainement que
nous on fera on fera notre justice pour
la criminologue Francette vignerons le
ou les empoisonneurs se sont lancés dans
une escalade criminelle je m’en prends
au chien mais vous vous les humains vous
leur mettre et vous la population
humaine
c'est quand je veux vous êtes à ma merci
je vous tiens j'ai commencé à m'en
prendre à vos chiens parce que
quand même le plus facile mais c'est le
plus symbolique
ensuite c'est vous donc faites ce que je
veux obéissez moi
laissez-moi vous dominer et peut-être
si tel est mon plaisir j'arrêterai
mais seulement si tel est mon plaisir
donc on a affaire à quelqu'un de très
dangereux
Égletons et dans les communes voisines
la psychose s'empare de la population
tout le monde soupçonne tout le monde le
procès de Roland bondoni devrait
permettre de faire enfin éclater la
vérité
24 joueurs 2003 palais de justice de
tulle à l'ouverture de l'audience tout
le monde se demande quel visage va
montrer Roland bondoni l'homme risque
jusqu'à deux ans de prison et 30 000
euros d'amende pour acte de cruauté sur
animal
nous sommes dans une ambiance d'assise
mais véritablement c'est-à-dire que vous
avez une salle principale qui est bon et
le monde noir de monde vous avez des
écrans installés à l'extérieur pour que
la foule les parties civiques ne peuvent
pas rentrer dans la salle les familles
les voisins puissent entendre et
participer au débat et donc vous avez
vraiment une ambiance lourde c'est très
pesant
on est dans une réelle ambiance d'assise
mais au dernier moment coup de théâtre
on annonce que Roland bandoni ne viendra
pas c'est son avocat qui apporte la
nouvelle
j'ai une pièce médicale
j'ai une pièce médicale et puis
j'attends de voir ce que décidera le
tribunal il est hospitalisé et
semble-t-il pour la journée on apprend
pas l'avocat du prévenu que son client
ne viendra pas car il aurait été
j'ai envie de dire bousculer pour ne pas
dire renverser par une camionnette de
livraison à 7h30 ou 7h ou 7h30 je me
souviens plus le matin sur le parking de
l'hôtel et que donc il est parti aux
urgences ça a fait les choux gras
ça a fait les choux gras le procès
renvoyé il a fait exprès c'est lui qui
s'est jeté sous la camionnette c'est
encore un trucage de sa part il ne veut
pas de son procès il a peur toutes les
sornettes que vous pouvez imaginer
Roland bandoni est examiné par un
médecin à l'hôpital de tulle il affirme
être victime de nausées de vertige de
fourmillements de douleurs aux
cervicales il dit qu'il ne peut se tenir
ni debout ni assis
mais client immédiatement sont
convaincus que c'est un coup monté pour
ne pas se présenter à l'audiante je suis
resté incrédule et encore aujourd'hui
j'ai jamais cru cette version bon
toujours est-il qu'il n'est pas venu
l'audience est reportée au 30 septembre
trois mois plus tard
il est arrivé tôt pour éviter la foule
Roland bandoni comparé libre il est
soupçonné d'avoir empoisonné des
dizaines de chiens et chats dans le nord
de la Corrèze les gens qui étaient là
contenaient leur hostilité la contenait
quelques fois mal on sentait une une
tension et une hostilité vis-à-vis de
vente était clair cette fois-ci Roland
bandoni se présente à son procès mais il
semble particulièrement énervé et face
aux caméraman qui le filme l'accusé va
perdre son sang-froid
tu veux comme ça [__] tu fais chier
toi
ça démontre le tempérament le caractère
de bon Denis
il ne supporte pas
d'être mis en cause pendant toute la
durée de l'audience Roland bondoni se
montre offensif voire agressif
n’hésitant pas à couper la parole aux
témoin subordonnée était égal à lui-même
il était très sûr de lui il était très
remonté il n'admettait pas ses mises en
cause et toutes ces contestations et
c'est vrai qu'il était très virulent
les gens ont peur
de témoigner contre bon Denis parce que
les gens disent si je parle il va [__]
le feu à ma grange
seuls deux chasseurs acceptent de
témoigner contre l'accusé l'un d'entre
eux n'est autre que Marius Lac
souvenez-vous le gendarme à la retraite
qui avait aiguillé les enquêteurs sur la
bonne piste
est vraiment le seul d'ailleurs son
témoignage et prononcé dans un silence
absolu et
il impressionne beaucoup les autres
témoins les parties civils justement
parce qu'il est il a le courage de
défier
de défier Roland
les menaces faites sur les chasseurs le
carbo furent retrouvé dans la
fourgonnette mais aussi l'attitude de
Roland bondoni achève de convaincre la
cour de sa culpabilité
à l'audience les les derniers mots de
Roland bandoni ont été
dans cette affaire je n'y suis pour rien
je n'ai jamais fait de mal à un chien et
cette phrase a été
comme un
suscité un sentiment de révolte parmi
les participes
encore plus fort que tout ce qu'il a pu
dire précédemment Roland bondoni a été
condamné à un an de prison ferme pour
avoir empoisonné plus de 140 chiens un
enferme et 111.000 euros de dommages et
intérêts le verdict est sévère Roland
bondoni fait appel immédiatement un
nouveau procédé doit être organisé
prochainement
nul n'imagine à ce moment-là que
l'affaire bondonie s'apprête à devenir
une affaire criminelle
[Musique]
un an plus tard fin août 2004 la
chapelle spinace un petit village
corrézien a quelques kilomètres
d'Égletons c'est ici que vit Marius Lac
le gendarme à la retraite qui a témoigné
contre Roland bandoni mais ce jour-là
son téléphone sonne dans le vide sa
fille Valérie cherche à le joindre son
succès inquiète elle téléphone alors aux
voisins Fernand gourinel
elle m'a dit d'aller voir que elle
pouvait pas joindre son père
et après avoir mangé
Fernand se rend donc chez son voisin
il trouve la porte de la maison ouverte
il appelle pas de réponse
Fernand se dirige alors vers le hangar
ou Marius Lac garçons 4x4 de marque Lada
derrière le ladage j'ai trouvé des
autour d'appartements
je continue un peu plus bas j'en ai vu
une autre il avait plu il y avait un peu
de boue
et ensuite je suis
je me suis avancé toujours et c'est là
que il y avait une brouette qui était
retournée comme ça
je l'ai attrapé
avec deux doigts
tout de suite j'ai vu que c'était Marius
et ça y est
il a assassiné
aussitôt Fernand prévient les gendarmes
le major Blazy est l'un des premiers sur
place le corps de Marius Lac bon est
simplement vêtu d'un short d'un t-shirt
présente des blessures assez importantes
au niveau du cuir chevelu à l'arrière et
sur le sommet du crâne
le rapport d'autopsie confirme la
sauvagerie du crime la tête a explosé
comme une coquille d'oeuf
[Musique]
montrant que Monsieur lac avait soit
reculé soit fui sur sur une dizaine de
mètres ce qui en soit était déjà une
indication puisque
je le rappelle le monsieur lac était un
ancien gendarme donc il était bien connu
des enquêteurs et ce n'était pas
quelqu'un qui était
enclin à fuir ou à reculer pour qu'il
ait fuit ou reculer ce qu'il y avait
vraiment eu quelque chose qui s'était
passé et qui était
très inexplicable au départ mais les
gendarmes vont faire une autre
découverte
sous le cadavre de Marius Lac un morceau
de papier
couvert de sang
[Musique]
on découvrons ceux qui semblent
correspondre à l'itinéraire depuis l'est
parisien donc jusqu'à en Corrèze
et de notre côté on retrouve également
donc l'adresse de Marius Lac numéro de
téléphone
bon ce numéro est ensemble en sous le
cadavre manifestement il a une relation
pour nous directe avec les avec les
faits dans la mesure où ce genre de
papier ensanglanté n'a pu tomber alors
soit de l'approche de l'agresseur soit
de la Porsche de la victime mais bon il
a forcément un intérêt avec la scène qui
s'est qui s'est déroulée
mot Melun Fontainebleau Montargis
Châteauroux Limoges tulle un itinéraire
qui mène de l'Est parisien jusqu'en
Corrèze
or le major Blazy connaît justement
quelqu'un de la région qui emprunte
souvent cet itinéraire il s'agit de
Roland bondoni
car le négociant en vain passe une
partie de l'année dans le nord de la
France plus précisément dans la ville de
Fourmies près de la frontière belge
bien entendu un rapprochement avec un
itinéraire qui est employé par Roland
bonnony bon quand il descend depuis le
nord de la France sur jusque sur la
Corrèze un itinéraire qui a quelques
lieux près correspond un petit peu à la
descente du nord vers le sud en évitant
un petit peu en passant par
incontournant Paris par l'est à la
gendarmerie de Tulle une cellule
composée de 10 gendarmes de la brigade
de recherche et chargée de l'enquête
[Musique]
un témoignage va se révéler essentiel
pour les enquêteurs celui de la fille de
Marius Lac Valérie quelques minutes
avant le meurtre elle se trouvait
justement au téléphone avec son père
quand l'arrivée d'une voiture rouge a
interrompu leur conversation on Valérie
là que la particularité de disons de son
témoignage c'est qu'ils vont on va dire
c'est une des dernières personnes
malheureusement à avoir entendu son père
puisqu'elle lui téléphone quand ce
véhicule rouge arrive dans les
sensations dans la cour de la fermette
alors effectivement Marius là que lui
dit que c'est un véhicule qui est
immatriculé dans le 02
donc je pense que chez elle ça amène
certainement une petite crainte
particulière parce que quelqu'un qui
vient de là d'un département étranger à
la Corrèze c'est pas habituel chez lac
qui est donc le chauffeur de ce véhicule
rouge immatriculé dans le département de
l'Aisne dans le nord de la France
les gendarmes vont tout mettre en œuvre
pour le retrouver
les enquêteurs qui sont chargés donc de
travailler sur cette hypothèse là donc
vont partir disons contacter donc tous
les endroits où ce véhicule a pu être
remarqué que ce soit donc sur les
autoroutes que ce soit en bordure de
route les garages les parkings d'hôtel
enfin partout où ce véhicule a pu un
véhicule semblable à plus donc et cela
sur la Corrèze bien entendu mais aussi
on commence à tenir compte de
l'itinéraire qui est trouvé sur le sur
le document
deux jours plus tard les enquêteurs vont
recueillir le témoignage d'une employée
du péage d'Égletons le soir du meurtre
aux environs de 22 heures un break rouge
s'est présenté au péage
son conducteur était un homme de 60 à 65
ans explique la jeune femme
il avait de grosses mains ce qui m'a
marqué c'est qu'il avait du sang sur les
mains j'ai remarqué aussi qu'il avait du
sang sur le visage
[Musique]
pour les gendarmes tout concourt à
accuser Roland Bondy l'itinéraire entre
le nord et la Corrèze le fait que la
victime Marius Lac était le témoin clé à
son procès et la description faite par
l'employé du péage de taureau
tout semble correspondre et pourtant les
gendarmes se trompent
[Musique]
le 31 août bondoni est donc entendu par
les gendarmes et la surprise l'homme
possède un alibi très solide le soir du
meurtre il ne pouvait pas tuer Marius
Lac en Corrèze car il se trouvait à 700
km de là à fourmi dans le département du
Nord
encore mieux il était en train de
déposer plainte dans un commissariat il
se présente au commissariat pour déposer
plainte pour un vol un vol à la roulotte
un vol dans son véhicule dans les
commissariats étant fermé bon on l'a
invité à revenir le lendemain mais il
insiste bien pour qu'on pointe son nom
pour qu'on prenne vraiment l'effet et
l'heure à laquelle se présente c'est
insistance là et puis la manière
d'opérer de l'individu bon nous ça nous
bon ça fait t-il quoi on pense quand
même malgré tout que c'est trop gros si
vous voulez cette c'est trop gros pour
pour ne pas avoir un lien direct avec
l'affaire la Libye de Roland bandoni
semble un peu trop parfait pour être
honnête le juge d'instruction pierre
baron décide de réagir aussitôt l'une
des façons de suivre cette piste était
de vérifier qu'elles étaient les
agissements et les déclarations de
Monsieur bandoni j'ai très rapidement ou
immédiatement autorisé donc de ce point
de vue là que les conversations du
portable monsieur gondini soit
d'intercepter et il se trouve que en
effet
qui est-ce bah c'est moi comment c'est
moi ah bon mais à la voix je comprends
mal je dis c'est moi c'est Alain oh
qui permet quand même de s'interroger
parce que manifestement abandonné il
coupe court très rapidement donc ça gêne
quelques jours plus tard une autre
conversation entre bondonie et le fameux
alain est intercepté
demain on fait ça à midi au numéro donné
oui au double numéro
les gendarmes se demandent quel est ce
double numéro auquel bon donner le
fameux Alain doivent se rappeler
en suivant Roland bandoni les gendarmes
vont l'apercevoir en train de téléphoner
dans une cabine et réussissent enfin à
localiser le fameux Alain monsieur
vandenis qui fait dès lors l'objet d'une
surveillance physique et vue un plan
d'une cabine téléphonique de Brive et
appelant une autre un autre numéro dont
on s'aperçoit qu'il correspond à une
cabine téléphonique double qui se trouve
à fourmis voilà donc ce que signifie la
formule codée double numéro une cabine
double devant la gare de fourmis ou
Roland bandoni donne des rendez-vous au
fameux Alain pour ne pas être écouté
c'est évident bondoni a quelque chose à
cacher
de son côté la cellule de recherche de
tulle a fini par retrouver la voiture
rouge immatriculée dans le 02
or son conducteur s'appelle justement
Alain Alain botchon
s'agirait-il de cette Alain acquis Bondy
à téléphoner à plusieurs reprises tout
le laisse penser
quelques jours plus tard les soupçons se
confirment les enquêteurs surprennent
une rencontre entre Roland bondoni et
Alain bochon cette fois la boucle est
bouclée le juge d'instruction ordonne
l'arrestation des deux suspects
Alain bochon ne sera pas difficile à
faire parler aussitôt après son
interpellation il va faire de longs
aveux aux gendarmes
ce sont des aveux circonstanciés qui
sont faits par Alain bochan qui
s'explique longuement 32 pages de garde
à vue c'est pas fréquent d'entrée de jeu
monsieur bouchon
passe aux aveux
dit qu'il a effectivement
tué Marius Lac qui l'a fait à la demande
de Monsieur brandoni s'il y Alain Bolson
a craqué immédiatement c'est que l'homme
n'a rien d'un tueur professionnel
c'est un homme simple maçon de son état
à fourmi tout le monde le connaît
Alain Bodson à 51 ans c'est quelqu'un
qui est décrit par tous les gens qui le
connaissent bien comme l'archétype du
brave type serviable désintéressée il
est issu d'une famille relativement
modeste dans sa vie il y a le travail et
la famille et voici ce que Alain Bolson
va raconter au gendarmes
botchon traîne souvent au bar Le
Gambetta c'est là qu'il a croisé il y a
quelques années la route de Roland bandi
[Musique]
moi après moi les deux hommes
sympathisent
Alain bolchon se laisse séduire par
bondoni le beau parleur commercial en
vin de Bordeaux
bochon va acheter du vin en grande
quantité 5000 francs à l'époque c'est
colossal alors que
bochon n'a pas le sous il est fauché il
est pas en mesure de payer d'ailleurs et
surtout il n'aime pas le vin de Bordeaux
c'est dire si déjà on gère il y avait
l'emprise de l'un sur l'autre d'après
Alain Bodson bondoni lui aurait un jour
confié qu'il avait des soucis avec des
voisins malintentionnés en Corée
[Musique]
il explique donc qu'on lui coupe ses
pieds de vigne il explique qu'on crève
ces pneus qu'on tue ses animaux et Alain
bolchan de dire et il m'expliquait cela
presque avec la larme à l'oeil en plus
il était bon comédien et bien Alain
bochon le croit parce que bon Denis se
pose en victime permanente le gentil
c'est lui une autre fois bondonie serait
les plus loin il aurait demandé à son
ami de l'aider à remettre à leur place
ces encombrants voisins
une demande au fil du temps de plus en
plus pressante
[Musique]
il n'avait de cesse de vouloir le
rencontrer lorsque votre champ faisait
un chantier à quelques dizaines de
kilomètres de son domicile
bon Denis faisait tout pour aller à sa
rencontre pour l'inviter à déjeuner et à
chaque fois il remettait ça sur le tapis
il faut que tu m'aides j'ai besoin de
toi
Roland bandoni a dit tout si je pouvais
trouver quelqu'un qui leur [__] la
trouille sur la marrangerait
étant donné que j'étais sous je lui ai
fait remarquer que s'il avait besoin un
jour il pouvait compter sur moi
lors d'une autre rencontre bondonie
aurait confié à bochon une arme de poing
[Musique]
avec la vague promesse d'être payé Alain
bolchon pense encore qu'il ne s'agit que
d'effrayer un voisin encombrant il
ignore que Roland bandoni a une toute
autre idée en tête
Alain botchon poursuit ses aveux auprès
des gendarmes
d'après lui Roland bandoni lui aurait
dicté la liste des villes à traverser
pour se rendre de fourmis jusqu'au
Corrèze
il lui aurait également indiqué deux
noms ceux des personnes qu'il était
censées effrayer et le premier de la
liste n'est d'autre que Marius Lac
[Musique]
enfin bon Donnie aurait cette foi était
très clair sur l'objectif du voyage
[Musique]
quel était le but de votre voyage je
devais tuer quelqu'un avec l'arme que je
détenais Roland bandoni m'avait demandé
d'en tuer l'un des deux sans déterminer
lequel mais en précisant néanmoins que
je devais tuer en priorité Marius like
car c'était le chef de bande
[Musique]
bondoni aurait aussi conseillé à botchon
de se faire passer pour un acheteur
intéressé par le 4 4 que l'ancien
gendarme cherchait à vendre
[Musique]
Alain bochon aurait eu le sentiment de
ne plus pouvoir reculer pour lui c'est
un notable qui lui demandait de faire
quelque chose et danser dans ses coins
là mais quand quelqu'un qui est haut
placé dans la société dit pour faire ça
mais je fais il en a marre du
harcèlement de bondonie et il se dit je
vais y aller et il cessera de
m'importuner
quelles étaient vos motivations pour
accomplir un tel acte j'avais besoin
d'argent et bon de Nil savait il m'avait
promis une somme d'argent sans pour
autant m'en préciser le montant
[Musique]
24 août 2004 4h du matin fourmis dans le
Nord
Alain bochon charge dans le break rouge
son VTT
et sous le siège avant il place le 765
chargé que lui a donné Roland Bondy
Alain bolchon respecte l'itinéraire
indiqué par Bondy
Meaux Melun Fontainebleau
mes amis chemins il affirment aux
enquêteurs qu'il s'est débarrassé du
pistolet
en le jetant d'un viaduc
il va se débarrasser de cette arme à feu
il va la jeter c'est quelque chose de
très important de capital parce que ça
prouve une chose ça prouve qu'elle a un
Botchan ne voulait pas tuer Marius Lac à
17h Alain bochon arrive à la
chapelle-spinasse
pour identifier la maison de Marius Lac
sans trop se faire remarquer il se
serait garé près d'un bois puis serez
redescendu en VTT
[Musique]
Alain bochon aurait repéré la maison on
apercevant le 4x4 de Marius Lac mais la
maison était vide il aurait rebroussé
chemin
vers 20h Alain bochon serait arrivé au
domicile de Lex gendarme
à son arrivée le retraité était au
téléphone avec sa fille
botchon ce serait présenté comme un
acheteur pour le 4x4 et Marius Lac
l'aurait accueilli
Alain Bodson aurait fait mine d'être
intéressé par la voiture du gendarme
Marius Lac l'aurait ensuite fait entrer
dans sa cuisine pour lui montrer les
factures du véhicule
c'est alors que les événements se
seraient précipités
Marius Lac serait retourné au hangar du
4x4 et la tout bascule
bonne chance suit Marius Lac bon
qu'est-ce qui lui passe par la tête il
dit bon pourquoi pas agir maintenant je
suis on est tous les deux il commence à
faire nuit
voilà donc c'est là je pense qu'il
commence à lui asséner des coups de
poing Marius Lac moi je vous dis je le
connais bien c'est pas quelqu'un qui va
se laisser faire et bon une bagarre
s'ensuit les deux hommes s'affrontent
Marius Lac se saisit d'une hache dans
son hangar pour se défendre
mais alors que l'ancien gendarme était à
terre bots lui aurait assez né un violon
coup de hache derrière le crâne
seulement Alain Bolson commet des
erreurs
d'abord il ne remarque pas que le papier
qui lui servait d'itinéraire est tombé
de sa poche
et puis plus tard au péage de
l'autoroute il ne pense pas à emprunter
la file des guichets automatiques c'est
ainsi que l'employé va remarquer ses
mains rouges de sang
[Musique]
Alain bochon conclut ses aveux en
expliquant que le lendemain il a
rencontré Roland bondoni dans un café
il m'a demandé si j'avais fait bonne
route je lui ai dit que ça avait été dur
mais que c'était fait il m'a demandé si
j'avais été repéré j'ai répondu que non
les aveux d'Alain bochon sont
implacables il correspondent en détail
avec tous les éléments de l'enquête
dorénavant le juge possède assez
d'éléments pour mettre Roland bondoni en
accusation mais cela va s'avérer plus
difficile que prévu
15 novembre 2004 au palais de justice de
tulle le juge organise une confrontation
entre Alain bolchon et Roland bandoni le
commanditaire présumé du meurtre mais
celui-ci affirme qu'il n'a rien à voir
avec le meurtre de Marius Lac ses
déclarations
je ne suis pour rien dans ce qui s'est
passé
l'avenir le démontrera beaucoup de gens
m'en veulent pour des raisons qui n'ont
rien à voir avec ce dossier mais c'est
je suis victime d'une cabale et je ne
suis pour rien dans ce qui s'est passé
bondoni affirme même qu'il ne connaît
pas Alain bolchon et que celui-ci n'est
qu'une fréquentation de comptoir
s il l'a connu il se parlait il mangeait
de temps en temps ensemble pour
parfaire le tableau monsieur bondoni et
corthum le nom de Monsieur Bodson qui
appelle Bottiau bout'chou et
pour bien montrer que finalement cette
personne lui est à peu près inconnue
pendant la confrontation Alain bochon
lui semble complètement tétanisé
il espère que le juge ne l'obligera pas
à regarder Roland dondoni lors de la
confrontation parce que il dit que cet
homme là envoûte les gens
bon Donnie n'avait de cesse d'essayer de
croiser le regard d'Alain Bashung et
Alain bolcho il supportait pas à ce
regard parce qu'il avait peur alors il
était obligé de baisser la tête et
j'essayais de me mettre entre les deux
pour faire barrage
et malgré les éléments du dossier malgré
les écoutes téléphoniques les
témoignages à charge et les aveux
d'Alain bolchon jamais Roland bandoni ne
va céder un pouce de terrain la
confrontation internationaux et Monsieur
abandoni s'est terminé par une question
de ma part à Monsieur bondoni en lui
demandant comment
ces les différentes constatations
matérielles qui avaient été faites et
qui le démentait comment il les
expliquait et Monsieur abandonné a eu
cette réponse quelle constatation
monsieur le juge
le monsieur aperçu qu'il était inutile
d'aller plus loin le dossier a été déjà
suffisamment nourri de ce côté-là
le juge d'instruction possède largement
assez d'éléments contre Roland bandoni
et Alain bochon les deux hommes sont
incarcérés à la maison d'arrêt de Tulle
en attendant leur procès
[Musique]
on Corrèze l'affaire passionne les
foules les journaux titres sur la grosse
somme d'argent promis à l'imbochon pour
tuer Marius Lac
la médiatisation fait surgir un nouveau
témoin le PDG d'une société qui produit
des engrais agricoles près de Fourmies
dans le Nord je viens d'être mise au
courant de l'affaire Bondy il achetait
toujours 10 kg de carburant prétextang
c'était pour traiter son champ de maïs
le carbo furent c'est cette insecticide
de couleur bleu qui a été utilisé dans
l'affaire des empoisonnements de chiens
d'après ce nouveau témoignage Roland
bandoni en a acheté de grandes quantités
sous un prétexte mensongé la position de
monsieur bourdoni qui jusque là avait
consisté à nier systématiquement tout
implication à nier ou sous-estimer très
largement ces relations avec Monsieur
Bodson
devenait de plus en plus difficile à
tenir
car là il est nécessairement qu'il
trouve une explication à un achat de
carburant qui avait été radicalement nié
et qui était quand même un niveau très
lourd dans le dossier
les taux se resserre autour de Roland
bondonnée dans l'affaire des
empoisonnements de chiens le témoignage
du marchand de carbo furant risque fort
d'alourdir la peine prononcée en
première instance
sans compter qu'un autre procès
s'annonce celui du meurtre de Marius Lac
et que cette fois l'ancien négociant en
vain risque la perpétuité
depuis la maison d'arrêt de tulle Roland
bondoni va alors prendre une décision
radicale
2 février 2005 maison d'arrêt de tulle
c'est aujourd'hui que doit avoir lieu le
procès en appel de Roland bandoni dans
l'affaire des chiens empoisonnées il est
6h du matin quand les gardiens de la
maison d'arrêt vont être alertés par un
détenu dans la cellule numéro 38 Roland
bondonis s'est donné la mort il s'est
pendu au barreau de son lit
[Musique]
au palais de justice de Limoges où le
procès en appel se prépare la nouvelle
sème la consternation les parties civils
présentent les participes physiques
présentes n'y croient pas n'y croient
pas et se disent monsieur une ultime
mascarade de bondonie c'est encore le
c'est encore voilà un mauvais épisode de
série B et tout ça et tout ça va se
voilà on va se réveiller et le procès
aura lieu et bien nous le procès n'a pas
eu lieu il est bien mort
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait la justice
première conséquence du suicide de
Roland bondoni toutes les actions
judiciaires contre lui s'éteignent plus
de complicité d'assassinat plus de
cruauté sur animaux comme tout juste
icible puisqu'il n'a pas été
définitivement jugé Roland bondonnier
reste présumé innocent
pour le justice que quelqu'un qui n'a
pas été définitivement condamné et
quelqu'un qui est innocent des faits qui
ont été reprochés et c'est le cas pour
Monsieur bon Denis c'est une des règles
de base de la justice et également de la
démocratie une règle difficile à
accepter pour les filles de Marius Lac
c'est pas juste pour mon père
c'est franchement pas juste ni pour les
gendarmes qui avaient fait du super
travail
il était là
pris au piège et par l'acheter
c'est pas enduit oui c'est fait je sais
pas quoi mais c'est pas juste
Bondy disparu c'est vers Alain bolchon
que se tourne l'attention des parties
civils et des médias
car dans l'affaire du meurtre de Marius
Lac il va se retrouver seul dans le box
des accusés
[Musique]
le 10 mai 2007 à Tulle deux ans après le
suicide de Roland bondoni s'ouvre le
procès d'Alain bolchon
et chose incroyable dans la salle
d'audience plane toujours le fantôme de
Roland Denis
qu'on avait vraiment l'impression à
certains moments que certaines témoins
avaient peur de le voir surgir encore au
détour d'un couloir ou dans la salle des
pas perdue de ce tribunal on a même des
gens qui ont pu penser qu'en réalité bon
Denis ne serait peut-être pas mort
qu'il serait passé sous le bistouri de
telle chirurgien esthétique et qu'il
vivrait peut-être des jours heureux en
Amérique du Sud ou ailleurs c'est dire
si à certains égards les gens étaient
dans le fantasme rapidement le débat va
tourner autour d'une question y a-t-il
eu préméditation le 24 août 2004
lorsqu'il a pris la route en direction
de la Corrèze Alain Bodson avait-il
l'intention de tuer Marius Lac ou
simplement de lui faire peur
pour la défense tout montre que le
meurtre n'était qu'un accident Alain
bolchon s'est débarrassé du pistolet
remis par brondonnier et c'est dans le
feu de la bagarre que le coup fatal a
été porté
il n'y a pas eu de préméditation à mon
sens parce que et le dossier le démontre
Alain botchon n'a aucunement planifié ce
qui allait se passer
Marius Lac est mort il n'a échafaudé
aucune stratégie un mode champ pour se
débarrasser du corps pour faire
disparaître les traces de son passage
mais pour l'accusation même s'il n'a
rien d'un tueur professionnel alain
bochon a bien prémédité son crime
monsieur bochon n'avait aucune raison de
donner de commettre un homicide
volontaire sur monsieur lac
sisney la commande préalablement passée
par Monsieur mononi de lui donner la
mort donc il y avait bien cet élément
préalable
d'une commande passée de donner
volontairement d'un contrat de donner la
mort à monsieur Marius contre
rémunération après quatre jours de
procès c'est la thèse de la
préméditation qu'il en porte
alain bochon est condamné à 22 ans de
réclusion criminelle pour le meurtre de
Marius Lac
chose rare dans pareil cas l'homme ne
fera pas à peine
quant à Roland bondoni faute de procès
il reste aux yeux de la justice à jamais
innocent